hollande prend la parole on va l'écouter
jure dizaines de tués il y a beaucoup de
blessés
c'est une horreur nous avons sur ma
décision
mobiliser toutes les forces possibles
pour qu' il puisse y avoir là près
neutralisation des terroristes et la
mise en sécurité de tous les quartiers
qui peuvent être concernés
j'ai également demandé qu'il y ait des
renforts militaires ils sont en ce
moment sur l'agglomération parisienne
pour être sûr que aucune attaque ne
puisse de nouveau avoir lieu
j'ai également convoqué le conseil des
ministres il va soutenir dans quelques
minutes
deux décisions seront prises l'état
d'urgence sera décrété ce qui veut dire
que certains lieux seront fermés la
circulation pourrait être interdite
et il y aura également des perquisitions
qui pourront être décidées dans toute
l'ile-de-france l'état d'urgence lui
sera proclamé sur l'ensemble du
territoire
la seconde décision que j'ai prise c'est
la fermeture des frontières
nous devons nous assurer que personne ne
pourra rentrer pour commettre quelques
actes que ce soit et en même temps que
ceux qui auraient pu commettre les
crimes qui sont hélas constaté puissent
également être appréhendée s'il devait
sortir du territoire
c'est une terrible épreuve qui une
nouvelle fois
nous assaillent nous savons d'où elle
vient qui sont ces criminels qui sont
ces terroristes
nous devons dans ces moments si
difficiles et j'ai une pensée pour les
victimes
très nombreuses pour leurs familles pour
les blessés nous devons faire preuve de
compassion et de solidarité
mais nous devons également faire preuve
d'unité et de sang froid face à la
terreur la france doit être forte
elle doit être grande et les autorités
de l'état ferme
nous serons nous devons aussi appelé
chacun à la responsabilité
ce que les terroristes veulent c'est
nous faire peur nous saisir d'effroi il
y a effectivement de quoi avoir peur il
y à l'effroi mais il y a face à l'effroi
une nation qui sait se défendre
qui s'est mobilisé ses forces et qui une
fois encore sera vaincre les terroristes
françaises français
nous n'avons pas terminé les opérations
il y en a encore qui sont extrêmement
difficiles
c'est en ce moment même que les forces
de sécurité font assaut notamment dans
un lieu à paris je vous demande de
garder ici toute votre confiance dans ce
que nous pouvons faire avec les forces
de sécurité pour préserver notre nation
des actes terroristes
vive la république et vive la france